I do Wonder okay I have noticed a
pattern with a lot of people who have
moved to Japan I wonder if you followed
that pattern oh no have you stopped
being a weeb have you have you stopped
watching anime or oh of course you bring
no actually I've watched more anime oh
really oh you're the one oh wait why
wait do people usually stop once we move
here well I mean like I feel yeah
because I know what God's talking about
it's like you know when you're visiting
Japan it's like all right our Cabra I'm
going there every [__] day you know
buying anime figures you know reading
manga watch anime blah blah blah and
then after like six months to a year I'd
say you're just like well maybe God our
camera once a year yeah because because
I was wondering these this Anime Cafe
I'm gonna call it a phase is it is it a
phase it's not a face is it a face style
it's a lifestyle was that purely for
Content or just do you genuinely just
love anime
but I'm like may as well make a video
about it if I'm going at this moment of
course especially since they're so
expensive but yeah I will watching more
anime isn't necessarily a result of me
have moving to Japan more like a result
of me living with Titus oh okay okay
yeah okay so he is the biggest Weaver
is
yeah so we I I've been watching a lot
more anime with because I thought about
you guys I don't like watching stuff by
myself I love it really no I actually
preferred watching it by myself yeah
yeah really no I I usually like having
another person like to experience it I
feel like that just Nerfs the experience
for me because I'm like now I have to
tailor my watching schedule around
another person as well and then what
happens is that we were like honey we
should watch this one show we watched
like two episodes where someone of us
gets a bit tired I wanna like one of us
might want to continue watching but no
we've got to stop for the other person
and then we're like we'll watch it when
we are next available and then we just
never finish it so that's that's why
that's that's why I'm just like I'd
rather watch by myself but you seem to
watch a lot more anime with ditus than
uh we're able to right yeah there's some
shows that I have been watching solo but
I feel like from most of the ones I've
watched It's usually with him right if
it's something he hasn't watched yet all
right recently uh we finished watching
Butchy The Rock
hell yeah hell yeah so there I I just I
love a good cute girls doing cute things
show yeah
we spoke about watching The Rock and
someone commented saying something like
Conor is everything that Bocce has an
irrational fear of
it I was like what does that mean that
is the most accurate that is the most
accurate comment I've ever heard what
why
because she has social anxiety and she's
afraid of meeting people like you
probably
yeah
she'd probably crumble under her own
pressure interacting with someone like
you I don't know do you still watch a
lot of Shoujo as well oh my God recently
I've been watching uh Yona of the Dawn
oh why what what is his reaction
it's so good there's there's been it's
one of the best yeah oh my God Hawk
oh yeah I saw you Tweeting about it and
I'm just like oh she's on that side now
I actually did want to watch it but then
I found out that it just like abruptly
ends and doesn't have a season two well
that's why you read the Manga after yeah
you continue with the manga a boy
I saw I saw an anime recently and I was
like this has the most Emily Aesthetics
which one sugar apple fairy actually
okay of course
oh [__] God I started watching sugar
apple fairy tale as well is this a
recent one yeah yeah it's this season
it's this season it's very pretty
if you if you put like strawberries into
an aesthetic it would be this show and
there's fairies yeah
Shame about the slavery in the show
though yeah
I was just like this is a really really
cute show explain the plot why is this
slavery because so humans have ins in
this world humans have enslaved fairies
yeah okay okay yes anime obsessed with
the slavery I don't know
it is kind of but the romance aspect is
a little weird because it's like she
buys a slime like a fairy this is like a
fully grown like dude by the way it's
it's like the no-called they're called a
worker thing guys guys
the work of fairies okay but uh that you
can buy as a property workers they're
working yeah I don't know how I feel
about the anime yet because I just
started watching it because so it's just
like Eagle slavery kind of thing yeah
like you know in like every Easter guys
like the guy buying like the slave but
like they're not like other slave owners
they're gonna treat the slavery nicely
yeah yeah yeah so she needs him to
escort her because she's trying to go to
like a confectionary Fair like
competition thing so question is this a
wholesome show yeah kind of no there's
like blood and stuff
there is isn't there yeah yeah because
because the title sounds like you know
something like really like sugar apple
you know cutesy and bubbly features
he is so hot by the way the warrior
fairy yeah but yeah I'm not a big fan of
like the romance Dynamic at the
beginning well of course I mean she
technically owns
he obviously like he distrusts humans
and doesn't like them for obvious
reasons right but he still like does
that weird thing where he's like teasing
her and like yeah yeah well I mean why
is this the Shojo genre yeah yeah but
it's like you have to ease into that
stuff you can't roll that out episode
one you can't oh he does that [__]
episode one episode one like like minute
12.
like why is this so sudden in episode
one there's there's this line that uh
there's a lot of yattas so they're
they're like this is you know after he
purchases him and they're in a carriage
going home together and she's like oh
I've never had my first kiss before and
he goes what are you a child I looked up
her age and she's 15 years and I was
just like yes she is a child
it's just like it's weird because you're
You're Expecting there to be a dynamic
of like they're bickering and like he
doesn't like her yeah yeah but at the
same time they're also trying to cram in
this Dynamic of like oh he's flirty with
her yeah and it's like it's just this
isn't working yeah that's that's a bit
weird yeah I was wondering what your
opinion was because like you know the
aesthetic is like you're aesthetic down
to the sea I feel for sure but beautiful
show looks like it's gonna pass on this
yeah I don't think you'd like it but
it's just I have to keep watching but
episode one I was like I'm not really
sold on this very much like the designs
are gorgeous but like I don't know I
don't know he he reminded me of like he
gave me the same ick as like usui from
kaichua maidsama oh okay huh my king he
gave me the same ick yeah yeah oh can
you relax like stop it yeah you're being
weird at least with Kaicho made someone
he wasn't a slave well yeah but he was
still weird
so actually the reason why I started
watching Yona of the Dawn is I had
already planned on watching it because
everyone was like this is such a you
show why haven't you watched it yet yeah
okay I should and
oh while we were watching the first
episode of sugar apple fairy tale Titus
was like you know what did this from
romance Dynamic way better and I'm like
what and he's like yelling of the Dawn
you should watch it yeah well you know
they're doing I feel like he's one of
the goats it's shocked oh yeah so good
and it's so beautiful I love it so far
I've
it's been a while since like I've
watched a show and like episode one my
mouth is like open but I'm like oh yeah
I watched episode one and two I think
and I don't really have any feelings on
it
I do remember stuff
yes
I also uh I'm currently on season two
I'm very behind on everything but I'm
currently on season two of uh Love is
War oh okay okay I love it I I think
season two is when like the last hour of
season two is when it really starts to
show its true colors really because we
loved season one I I was like I didn't
love season one I was like this is
enjoyable and then season two made me
care about the characters because they
actually like get characters I can't
it's one of those shows where like I
can't watch it without grinning yeah
every episode it's because it's like
it's genuinely fun yeah because when you
wear this we had this conversation in
previous podcasts about how we're
getting it like a little bit tired of
like romance anime and manga what do you
think makes a good romance like Dynamic
well what like what like draws you to a
romance dynamic
okay well a good rom-com has to be funny
funny and like sort of unpredictable
yeah a good romance
I've noticed that the romance anime that
I'm most drawn to is very gradual like
well I feel like it has to right because
otherwise then it becomes unrealistic
you know if if the romance happens too
fast then it's like that's that doesn't
happen in real life yeah in real life
we're like dude
my love my love story it happens pretty
quickly but it's still like
super cute I guess but they they still I
feel like in my love story they still
you know like like the start is fast but
then like actually them developing is a
long process you know oh my God whereas
like I've seen some romance anime where
it's like you know episode one they meet
and then by episode three they're like
[__] and I'm like oh chill bro like
where's the build up yeah
you know so it's like I feel even if
like the start is fast like in my love
story like if if the progression is like
slow yeah then it's like oh it's more
realistic so you get more attached to
the characters yeah right whereas like
from this [__] sugar apple show I
feel like immediately it's already like
yeah yeah
it kind of yeah I like it you know it's
the best when like you can really sense
their individual personalities yeah and
you enjoy watching them on screen even
if it's just them like by themselves
yeah I mean it was kind of refreshing
for me to see just to see more modern
Shoujo anime being made that's not like
a rehash of a very old franchise or
something because I feel like show your
anime are just getting way way more
unpopular now or like less is less is
being met it's not yeah less is just
being made in the modern day I think
good
excuse you
yeah no I agree because there's so many
good shows and rip-offs yeah